[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON BAEK: In Korean,
we say hi, [KOREAN],,
so please use it in Korea
when you visit someone.
Yeah.
I really appreciate you
joining this session
because I have never expected
such a huge audience as this,
because it's the last session
of the Google Cloud Next.
I really appreciate it.
In this session, there
are three speakers.
I'm Jason, customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
I look after Netmarble.
And Etsuji Sensei,
we usually call
him Sensei, the great teacher.
He's a solutions
architect at Google Cloud,
who has strong expertise
in AI and machine learning.
And Jennifer is the team
member of Netmarble, who
is a very talented ML engineer.
So here are contents.
In this session,
we're going to talk
about the case
studies of Netmarble
in terms of anomaly
detection in MMORPG.
So in the beginning,
I'm going to talk
about the brief introduction
about Netmarble,
and what is their business
and why they chose machine
learning to detect of users.
So after that, Etsuji will be
presenting about the challenges
that they have faced to
leverage machine learning models
in order to detect
anomaly detections.
He's going to present
about the solutions
that Netmarble is
currently using.
And after that, Jennifer is
talking about the collaboration
between Google
Cloud and Netmarble
in order to accelerate
their process
and also enhance the model.
And after that,
Jennifer and I will
be talking about the next steps
about the deploying multiple ML
pipelines and also empowering
the detecting powers.
And there is the Dory
in the cloud apps.
So you can have questions very
freely by using the Dory Q&A.
So in order to use Dory Q&A,
please open the Cloud Next app
and tap our session, and you can
submit your questions to Dory.
Then, we're going to
handle the questions.
But unfortunately,
we have limited time
so we are not going to
handle during the session.
But I promise that I'm going to
handle every question, so feel
free to submit your questions.
So I'm going to talk about the
brief introduction of Netmarble
and their business,
and I'm going
to give you the
reason why Netmarble
chose machine learning to detect
those kind of abnormal users.
This is a brand logo, and the
brand symbol of Netmarble.
The brand symbol is
a yellow dinosaur.
It looks like alligator,
but yeah, dinosaur.
So the dinosaur is named Ke Ke.
Ke Ke means just
laughing in Korean.
So when we usually
have fun, then we just
say ke ke ke ke-- yeah,
something like this.
So we usually have
fun, then we just
say ke ke in a text message.
So the name is very related
with Netmarble's missions.
So Netmarble's mission
is entertaining the world
with the fun games.
So Netmarble usually tries
to deploy and release
the fun gaming [INAUDIBLE]
to entertain the real world.
And here's some numbers
presenting Netmarble.
As you can see,
Netmarble is third,
the game publishers in global.
And also, they already
acquired 68 million
monthly active users.
This number is larger than
whole career populations.
So we can see Netmarble is
focusing not only on Korea,
but also global business.
In order to entertain the
world, Netmarble already
has 19 subsidiaries as
development studios,
and 5,000 plus employees
as game developers.
Here are key products
of Netmarble.
So the left two things are
"Blade and Soul Revolution,"
"Lineage to Revolution,"
which are mobile MMORPG.
So those two products are
really popular in Asia,
and they're generating
more than $100 million.
And also, the right
two things are
very popular in Korea named
"The Seven Knights," and also--
you know Marvel, yeah?
This is a Marvel game.
So the "Marvel Future
Fight" hit the world,
and they just acquired the
millions of users in the world.
So as you can see, the
key products of Netmarble
are high fidelity
games, which is
easily to acquire [? lower ?]
users, and also heavy spenders.
So servicing a
high fidelity game
is very important to
create big revenues.
And their key success
factors are two things.
The first thing
is that acquiring
the heavy spenders who
are willing to spend
more than $100,000 for a game.
Yeah, it's crazy, but true.
Yeah, really true.
And the second
thing is retaining
that kind of heavy spenders
in a long lifetime.
So in order to do
this, Netmarble usually
leverages the most
famous eyepiece,
such as "Marvel Future Fight."
Yeah, it used the Marvel IP.
And "Lineage 2" and "Blade and
Soul" is developed by NCSOFT,
but it's really popular in Asia.
So Netmarble leveraged
these IPs to acquire
most of the heavy spenders.
And in order to retain those
kind of heavy spenders,
Netmarble should manage the
ecosystem of the MMORPG game
because if the heavy spender
feels that someone is stronger
than me without spending any
money, then they just, yeah,
oh.
This is just an unfair game.
And they just leave the game.
Yeah.
They just leave the game.
And they just try to
find another MMORPG.
So managing the ecosystem
is the most key part
of the success of the
high fidelity game.
So Netmarble usually tries
to manage the ecosystem.
But as you know, so
many people are coming,
then someone will be a bad guy.
So in this case, we
call them abusers.
So there are some of the
abusing cases in MMORPG.
The first case is
that they tried
to abuse the bug of some of
the marketing events or content
updates.
So for example, the TeraM has
some bugs in our promotions.
So some abusers, they cheated
to get some multiple reward
by clicking multiple times.
Due to that issue, it
made high inflation
of the gaming economy.
So the most of
the heavy spenders
[? turned ?] very immediately.
And the second thing is
that some of the abusers,
they just tried to hack
the client vulnerabilities,
such as the memory
hacking, or just
trying to send some
multiple messages to get
multiple rewards.
And also, the last thing is
that some genius hackers,
they usually use
this leverage as BOTs
to generate in-game
resources automatically.
So some abusers, they're
just running 10,000 BOTs
to generate in-game
resources, and they just
try to sell it to the market.
So Netmarble tried to
block those kind of users
by using rule based model
because it's really accurate,
and it's very easy
to understand.
So when Netmarble planned
to release the game,
they just designed
the business model.
At this time, the
business development team
also designed the rules
to detect some abusers.
For example, if someone reached
out to the 100 level in a week,
then that kind of player
might be an abuser candidate,
something like this.
And after the rule is
designed, then they just
send it to the development
team to ask some game logs
to check their user behaviors.
And also, the QA team
verifies whether the laws
are successfully stored.
And after that, they will
be releasing the title.
And let me assume
that the game logs
are successfully
store to the storage.
Then, business intelligence
team try to investigate,
and they just analyze the
gaming logs to analyze the user
behaviors, and they just
apply some of the rules
to the rule based
model, and they just
run the rule based
model in production.
Then, the rule based model
will be detecting some abuser
candidate, and the
rule based model
will be notifying
to the ops team
to investigate if this abuser
candidate is an abuser or not.
So ops team and
development studio
collaborate to investigate
those kind of user activities.
And also, if that abuser
candidate is truly an abuser,
then they just block the users.
And if that is a false alarm,
then the intelligence team
changes the code, and
they modify the rules
to detect the right abusers.
But as you can
see, so many teams
are engaging in
so many processes,
and it takes a long time
to modify and change
the rule based model.
So as you've seen,
there are some problems
to run the rule based model.
The first one is that honestly,
it has the small coverages
to detectable users
because it's actually
working on rule based model.
So if someone is
abusing without rules
or without some
unpredicted behaviors,
then the rule based
doesn't expect
this is an abuser or not.
And as you see, it's
really hard to keep up
with the speed of the content
updates and new patterns
because mostly, in order to
retain the heavy spenders,
the most important thing is
that the development studio
keep continuously updating
the content to spend money.
So mostly, they are focusing
to develop the game features,
and they usually
de-prioritize to adding
the new rule based model.
So it's really hard to
maintain the rule based model.
Due to those issues,
Netmarble tries
to decide to leverage the
ML technologies in order
to learn from the user behaviors
instead of adding something
by hand.
So in this section, Etsuji--
Sensei-- will be presenting
about the challenges
of what Etsuji
and Netmarble have
faced to leverage ML models.
And also, he's going to give
you the solutions that Netmarble
model is currently using.
So please welcome
Etsuji on the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK.
Thank you, Jason.
And good to see you, everyone.
I'm Etsuji Nakai, I am
a solutions architect
for Google Cloud Platform.
I'm based in Tokyo, Japan.
And as you know, the
customer, Netmarble,
is a company based in Korea, so
I traveled quite a little times
last year to Korea
to meet the customer
and help them develop the
machine learning model
to solve the problem that
Jason has just explained.
And I conducted machine
learning workshops, for example,
several times.
Actually, quite a lot of times.
And of course, I'm not
complaining about it.
It was lots of exciting, very
pleasurable experience for me
because some of you
may know that having
a conversation about machine
learning with a customer
is always challenging.
Because it requires a variety
of knowledge for both of us.
First, we must understand
what is machine learning.
We must know the
nature of the data set,
and we must know
the business goals.
In other words, we must
have the domain knowledge.
In this case, it is a knowledge
in the gaming industry.
And in that sense, the
collaboration with Netmarble,
the data scientist
team in Netmarble
was a perfect example for me.
Because in Netmarble, they have
a very strong data scientist AI
team focusing on AI technology.
They have a very
good understanding
about machine learning, and they
know the nature of their data
set, and they are naturally the
experts of the gaming industry.
So what about the Google side?
First, I'm a machine
learning expert.
I have very deep knowledge
on machine learning.
I can say that.
However, I don't
have much knowledge
in the gaming industry.
I don't play mobile
games very much.
I'm sorry, Jennifer.
[LAUGHS] However,
on the Google side,
we have the customer
engineer, Jason.
He has a very deep
knowledge and experience
in the gaming industry.
So by sharing our
experience and knowledge,
we collaborated very
successfully together
to achieve the business result.
And for now, I will explain
some critical details
of the machine learning
model they developed together
with us to detect abnormal
users or abnormal data.
This is a very short answer.
They use the machine learning
model called old encoder
to detect abnormal data.
This is a very simplified
diagram of the old encoder.
But actually, the mechanism
of old encoder is very simple.
It is a machine learning model
to regenerate the same data
as input on the outside.
So we try and do some
action on a model
to minimize that delta
between input and output.
And the question
is, how and why we
can use this machine learning
model to detect abnormal data?
To explain that, I prepared
a simple, tiny toy model
using the [INAUDIBLE] data set.
[INAUDIBLE] data set is,
as you know, the collection
of handwritten digit images.
We barely know if
we use this data set
to explain some basic
mechanism of machine learning.
So this is a kind of
"hello world" example.
But anyway, I will
show you some code.
OK, can you turn to
the demonstration?
OK.
This is a collab notebook.
I implemented a tiny toy
model on this notebook,
so let me go through
this notebook.
First, I import
some module, and I
download the
[INAUDIBLE] data set,
and I define the machine
learning model, old encoder.
I don't explain
details of the code,
but if you know
about [INAUDIBLE],,
you can understand
what's happening.
I define the very simple neural
network model with six layers,
and I will train this
machine learning model
to minimize the delta
between input and output
by using the MSE, mean squares
error, as a loss function.
And I will train this machine
learning model, initially,
with just a little data, only
for a single [? epoch. ?]
And this season is out.
The top side is the input
data, and the bottom side
is the output data.
You can see that
this model is now
trying very hard
like a small child
to re-generate the same
data, but it's not perfect.
So I will keep training.
I trained this model
with some additional data
for more [? epochs. ?]
And you will
see the result. Like this one.
OK, it's far better now.
And now, I will use
this trend model
to detect some abnormal data.
OK, I draw some number
on this white canvas.
And first, I try some simple
one, just number zero.
And you see the
result. The output
is very similar to the input.
And now, I try
something different.
I draw, not a
number, but a letter,
B. Can you guess
what would happen?
AUDIENCE: They [INAUDIBLE].
ETSUJI NAKAI: Yes the output
is different from letter B.
It looks like number
eight or number three.
Yeah, this is because I trained
this machine learning model
with only numbers,
so it always tried
to re-generate some
data similar to numbers.
So in this case, the
output is totally
different from the input.
So by comparing the
input and the output,
you can say that the
delta is very large.
This input is different
from training data.
This is something
different from the numbers.
This is a basic mechanism.
Can you go back to
the presentation?
OK.
So once you train this
machine learning model
with no more data, you can use
this machine learning model
to detect abnormal data by
comparing the input and output.
Very good.
However, now you are faced with
technical challenge number one,
no labeled data.
As I told you, you need to train
this machine learning model
with only normal data.
To do that, you have to
split up your whole data set
into two parts, normal
part and abnormal part.
How can we do that?
We need a machine
learning model for that.
So this is a chicken
and egg problem.
I think this is a very common
problem in the gaming industry.
Generally, they
have a lot of data,
but they are not well organized.
They need some tricks
to organize those data
so that they can use that
data for machine learning.
However, sometimes
you need machine
learning itself to do that.
So we had several discussions of
how we can solve this problem.
And our solution is
surprisingly simple.
We used the whole data,
including abnormal ones,
to train this machine
learning model.
And naturally, we have several
assumptions behind that.
One of the biggest
assumption is that the amount
of abnormal data
is very, very small
compared to the normal data.
So the inference
of abnormal data
would be simply overwritten by
the huge amount of normal data.
Of course, this is
just an assumption.
We have to verify that.
We tried several different
machine learning models
to check our assumption.
And finally, it actually worked.
Sounds good?
I guess some of you are now
thinking, this is too simple.
This is different from
what I expected to hear.
Yeah.
However, in reality,
the most important part
of applying machine
learning to your business
is to choose the best and
simplest machine learning model
to solve your problem.
It is a very tricky part.
To do that, you
have to understand
variety of machine learning
models, pros and cons of them.
And you need to choose
the best and simplest one.
It's very hard.
And that's why I'm here.
I can help you for that.
I actually have
Netmarble for that.
Anyway, before going to explain
another technical challenge,
I want to explain the production
use case of this machine
learning model.
Now, they re-train this machine
learning model every day
using that fresh data
in past two days.
And after re-training the
machine learning model,
they deploy the trained model
to the production system.
And then, they used
the similar time gaming
[? log ?] data to
detect abnormal users.
And then, they create a
list of suspicious users
and send the list to
the operational team.
And finally, the
operational team
does manual further
investigation
to have complete evidence
that some users did actually
something that wrong.
And then, they decide
the appropriate action
against those bad users.
And again, you may
have some questions.
First question is, why
we have to re-train
the model every day.
Because the data
freshness matters.
In the world of online
gaming, especially in MMORPG,
the user behavior always
changes due to some reasons.
Sometimes they have
some, in gaming events,
the latest new game features
and characters every day.
And even without those
elements, maturity of users
naturally influence the
behavior of those users.
So it's a kind of natural
evolution in the virtual gaming
world.
So to keep up with these
changing realities,
we have to re-train the model
every day with fresh data.
And the second question is,
why manual investigation?
Isn't it machine learning
to automate everything?
Isn't it a good idea to
automatically log bad users?
Unfortunately, it's not a
good idea for several reasons.
One of those reasons is
to avoid false positives.
It's really bad if we block
some normal users mistakenly.
It's the last thing
we want to do.
And the second
reason is to decide
the appropriate actions
against bad users,
it's sometimes very tricky.
Suppose that we found several
users who did something wrong,
just one time from curiosity.
And what if they're
a very loyal user?
They spent a lot of
time for that game.
They spent a lot of money.
In that case, simply
blocking those users
is not a right
business decision.
So they have to
understand the real nature
of those bad behaviors.
They have to understand the
real nature of those users
to decide the appropriate
action against them.
That's why they need a
manual investigation.
And the last reason is
somewhat interesting.
By doing manual
investigation, they
can understand some new
patterns of abnormal behaviors
and apply that knowledge to the
existing learning based model
to improve them.
You may have thought that once
we created a machine learning
model, we can throw away all the
existing old rule based model.
It is not the case.
In some cases, rule
based model works better
than machine learning.
It is a reality.
So combining machine learning
and a rule based model
is the ideal solution.
And in this
particular case, they
can get new insights
about the new patterns
of abnormal behaviors
because machine learning
is very good at finding
new patterns automatically.
And then, they can
use that new finding
to improve the existing
rule based system.
So this is a very
good virtual cycle.
OK.
Now, we are faced with the
critical challenge number two.
It is model explainability.
What does it mean?
Because the
operational team needs
to do some manual investigation,
they need some hint.
Why did this machine
learning model
detect these users as abnormal?
Without any reason, they can't
do the manual investigation
effectively.
They need some hint from
the machine learning model.
This is a problem
that we generally
call model explainability.
And to solve this problem,
the AI team in Netmarble
applied the feature engineering.
It means instead of
using the original log
data to train the
machine learning model,
they combined those
log data, log features,
to create some new features.
Those are interpretable
and explainable.
And then, they used
those engineering
features to train the
machine learning model.
And after the training, they can
compare the delta between input
and output for each feature.
If some specific feature
has a large delta,
it is exactly the reason why
this machine learning model
detected this user as abnormal.
And this feature
is interpretable.
Operational team can
use this information
to do further manual
investigation effectively.
And this is the overview of
the feature engineering the AI
team in Netmarble applied.
The original data is
naturally a time freeze data
because this is gaming log data.
And they aggregated
this time freeze data
with 60 minutes time window
to create new interpretable
features.
And you can see some
functions or formulas
they used to aggregate, to
create interpretable features.
Unfortunately, details of
these features or formulas
are confidential.
These are very, very important
intellectual property
of Netmarble.
They cannot disclose everything.
But if you have some
knowledge in data science,
or at least statistics,
you can guess
what they are doing to create
some interpretable features.
OK.
And this is the
last slide for me.
Instead of using the standard
normal, old encoder model,
they decided to use stacked
denoising autoencoder
to detect abnormal users.
I don't have much
time to explain
what is denoising autoencoder,
but I will give some keywords.
The most important keyword
is spill over effect.
By using the
denoising feature, you
can avoid the spill over
effect of standard old encoder.
And by avoiding the
spill over effect,
you can improve the
explainability of the model.
If you are really
interested in that,
you can search some
academic papers
with the key word,
denoising autoencoder,
and the spill over effect.
Basically, by avoiding
a spill over effect,
you can specifically
identify the feature,
which affects the delta
between input and output.
Please search some academic
papers for details.
OK.
Anyway, now Jennifer
from Netmarble
will talk about some technical
details of their machine
learning pipeline, and how
we have collaborated together
to achieve the actual
business result.
Please welcome
Jennifer to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER OH: Thank you
for having me, Etsuji.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Jennifer Oh.
I am an ML engineer
in Netmarble,
and I was also a key member of
[INAUDIBLE] detection project.
I'm here to share two
kinds of challenges we had
and how we solved them.
Before we start, there's
a little dinosaur
on the right top of the screen.
You might want to check how the
emotion changes by each slide.
Anyways, so the first
challenge was this.
We have so many game titles.
And these game titles have
unique user behaviors.
As you can see on
the screen, there
are some MMORPG games, adventure
RPG games, and also others.
And these games have a
very different data schema
in their distribution, since
all the games were made
by our subsidiary companies.
So therefore, we could not train
all the data into one model.
That means we needed at least
one model product per game.
That's a huge amount
of model products.
So we thought that we needed
a standardized platform that
could handle multiple
model products.
So the solution for
this was simply GCP.
Using GCP, we could
standardize this whole system.
Let's check out them in detail.
So using GCP, we did not
have to manage the machines
and services since
they are all managed.
And we did not have to make
new API functions since most
of them are already made.
So even if we had
new game titles,
which require new functions,
we did not have to make them.
Also, it was easy
to change the system
scale, which is very important.
Whether you want to use
distributed environment or not,
or no matter how large
scale you want to use,
we did not have
to change anything
except a line in your config
file or the CLI command.
Let's say suddenly,
a game's DAU has
doubled in a day, which
might happen in a few games.
So the data size
would be doubled too.
In that case, normally we
have to add some new machines,
do some setups, and test.
But in our case, we
don't have any worries.
Like, what's the
big deal about it?
All we have to do
was to just change
the number of nodes
from 10 to 20.
So with these reasons, we
were able to standardize
this whole system.
So let's check out our
system architecture.
As you can see on the
screen, all the game data
was saved on BigQuery.
So we use Dataflow to
extract data from BigQuery
and do pre-processing.
And all the pre-processed data
would be saved on [? GCS. ?]
Using the CSV files, we run
a training job on ML engine.
When the training job is done,
the exporting model will be
saved on [? GCS. ?] So using
the files saved on [? GCS, ?] we
can register the model on
an engine so that we can use
as prediction.
Let's move on to the
production process.
So starting from the
preprocessed files,
which is same as
the training part,
we run a prediction
job on ML engine.
And when the
prediction job is done,
the predicted results would
be saved on [? GCS. ?]
And we can just upload
the CSV files to BigQuery,
and then send the predicted
results to our customers, which
are the operational team.
So all this process is
also scheduled by Jenkins.
The processes are run every
day, or maybe even every hour.
So guesstimate how
many people we need
to manage this whole system.
Just one or maybe even less.
So if we want to apply
an anomaly detection
to a new game, all we
have to do is to do data
EDA and some feature selection,
since all the game data are all
different.
And we might do some preparation
for the data pre-processing,
and change the model
parameters, and it's
ready for the production.
So that's it for
the first challenge
we had, and let's move
on to the next challenge.
So this is our next
challenge we had.
So we wanted good
model performance.
So in order to do that, we had
to read more papers and blogs,
and run some tests
with multiple models.
However, we were
running out of time,
and we did not have
enough human resources.
So we chose to
collaborate with Google.
Let's check them in detail.
So the first thing
we did was having
workshop with Etsuji Sensei.
So we explained our
situation and our problem,
and he shared his
thoughts and ideas.
So we did architecture
brainstorming together
and model algorithm
brainstorming together.
And after a few days, he
gave us a fantastic idea
about unwanted detection, which
our current system is mostly
based on.
Thank you, Etsuji.
So we had the idea.
And the next thing we had
to do was run some tests
with multiple model
algorithms and find which
one is the best for our system.
So the next thing we chose
to do a Google PSO project.
Netmarble and the
PSO team ran MVM
about different model
algorithms in parallel,
such as statistical model,
LSTM deep autoencoder,
and stacked denoising
autoencoder.
With the results
from each team, we
were able to choose the best
model that fits our system.
There were also many
supports from the Google
technical account managers and
customer engineers like Jason.
And also, we had BespinGlobal,
our GCP partners.
They were there to help us when
there was any problem with GCP.
And also, they
shared some updates
so that we can prepare
for the update.
And also, they
provided many supports
so we could have a smooth
collaboration with Google.
As a result, we
finished our product
successfully and efficiently.
What I mean by
efficiently is that we
only used few human
resources and also few time.
Let's check the model results
as a developer's perspective
and also user's perspective.
This is a graph showing
number of users daily.
As you can see on
the graph, there's
a light blue graph,
which is showing
the number of suspicious
users detected by the model.
The dark blue ones
are the ones who
are blocked by the
operational team.
So as you can see, most
of the users detected
were investigated by
the operational team,
and they were turned out to
be abusers using hack tools.
So they were blocked from
playing the game again.
This is a graph showing the
number of abusers reporting
posts on the public web page.
So if normal users see abusers
when they are playing game,
they put some post to
complain about the abusers
or to request us to block them.
They will get angry if they see
the abusers winning so easily.
So the number of abuser
reports used to be that high.
But once the anomaly
detection was released,
the number on the graph
dropped down steeply.
This happened because the
coverage of the ML model
was much larger than the
original rule based model
that Jason has explained.
So that saved for the
challenges we had.
And let's move on
to the next part.
So from now on, let's
find out about things we
are going to doing the future.
Until now in Netmarble, we
were running many AI projects
besides the anomaly detection.
There's ad fraud
detection, which
is detecting some
fraud information sent
by the ad company.
There's ROAS prediction,
which is predicting
a return on ad spent.
There's gold farming
detection, which
is detecting users who
run thousands of posts
to collect real game resources.
There's test automation,
which is using AI model
to run a game function test.
There's auto balance
evaluation, which
is also using AI model to test
the game values automatically.
And also, last but not
least, the voice command,
which is playing game
automatically using the user's
voice.
Well, in the future, we are
planning to do more and more AI
projects.
We are going to extend AI
to all of our businesses.
And we are going to
enhance partnerships
with Google, of course.
And we are going to do more
collaboration and cooperation
with Industry University and
also Japan and North America AI
companies.
So that's it for
the Netmarble side,
and let's hear more about
the technical side by Jason.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON BAEK: Thank you, Jennifer
for the [? best ?] messages
for us.
So we are still very closely
working with Netmarble
in order to enhance their
ML models and ML pipelines.
So we are trying to do some
technical challenges still.
So the first thing is that we
are collecting labeled data.
As Etsuji mentioned,
it's really hard
to collect labeled data in
reality because no abusers,
they don't want to get seen.
Yeah, they just want to hide.
So in order to leverage
the current models,
the detecting power is
increased up to 10 plus times.
So we are collecting
more blocked users.
And we are just
thinking, what if we
can leverage those kind of
blocked users as labels?
So if we can leverage
those kind of blocked
users and their features,
and user behaviors,
then we can develop the
supervised learning models.
So autoencoder is based on
the unsupervised learning
by clustering some
player behaviors.
So we're also trying to
leverage the supervised model
by leveraging blocked
user information.
And second, the challenge
is that we are still
revamping ML pipelines.
So as Jennifer mentioned,
all the ML pipeline
is based on the many solutions.
But Netmarble chairman
is very satisfied
with the performance
of current models,
so he's encouraging to
deploy their ML model
to new releasing gaming titles.
It means that they have
to manage more than 10
plus ML models in this year.
In order to support
this, we are trying
to migrate their ML pipeline
to Kubeflow pipeline
to accelerate the
model development.
And the last part is that we are
trying to do ensemble learning.
So as Etsuji mentioned, we are
not only using single model,
but also we are leveraging
rule based model.
And we are trying to use
the supervised learning
model and the other models
to empower the detection.
So we are trying to
use ensemble learning.
So hopefully, next
year, I'm going
to give you more detail
about our challenges.
So that's it.
Thanks for having this session.
And I want to give you one more
thing is that your feedback is
highly appreciated.
So before you leave the stage,
please complete the survey
on the Cloud Next app.
Thank you, everyone.
[KOREAN] Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]